hi I'm Eric Minich with IBM cloud I want
to talk a little bit about continuous
delivery which is all about how do I
quickly get code into production you
know continuous delivery as a term goes
all the way back to the agile manifesto
and the first principle of that says
what's really important is that we
satisfy our customers through the early
and continuous delivery of valuable
software so if we're in a place where
we've got valuable changes to the code
and if our changes aren't valuable we
probably should be making them but if
we've got valuable changes to our code
we want to get in production how do we
do that that's what continuous delivery
is all about
well the first step here is that we've
got code not software so we need to turn
it into software that's our build
process right good now we've got
software we've got production we could
just deploy the software into production
so what we're gonna do no what we're
really gonna do is a whole bunch of
testing to make sure that what we have
actually belongs out there so most
companies I work with have anywhere from
two to five test environments they'll
have an environment name something like
QA right in another environment name
something like performance or stage well
we can use those all right so we take
our software we put in the QA
environment we put it in the staging
environment and we and put it out in
production all right I always should
probably do some testing too so this is
kind of the backbone or the the path to
production in continuous delivery when
you look at a continuous delivery tool
or you look at continuous delivery
pipeline you'll often see this kind of
perspective I have builds and I put them
out in production now what are the
activities here what are the key
behaviors so the first one is this
migration that we see right
so we can look at that migration this
migration this migration let me say okay
this requires an automatic deployment
right auto deploy this is where we see
tools like application release
automation continuous delivery pipelines
very focused on how do my builds move
through the environments what's the
order of the environments how do I
manage and govern that right are there
rules for when I need to move from here
to here to here that kind of content the
next side of this is it's not just about
moving the bits right if we're just
moving things around the only thing that
we've tested is that we can actually
deploy our software that's valuable but
we're probably have all these
environments because you know down in QA
and staging we were doing some automated
testing all right supporting a
continuous testing kind of approach as
part of our overall continuous delivery
and then we're probably also using some
tooling down here that we care about
this would be our continuous integration
server that does our builds all right
the idea of a building manager
continuous integration server of all
come together
so here the the key pieces final idea
typically in continuous delivery this
transition here moving from stage to
prod is gonna have another level of
governance on it you might be in a
fully-automated situation where code
commit comes into github there's a
trigger that tells the build server new
codes here it automatically does a build
it triggers an appointment to QA which
automatically triggers our tests if
those pass we automatically trigger out
to stage which automatically triggers
more tests that's great it's continuous
it's fast when we're down here when
we're looking at this move to prod
almost always we're looking at some sort
of a human getting involved this
storica Lee that was your change
approval board your cab ideally if we're
automating all of our testing we're
getting all the data we're able to
automate the cab out of existence and
just say hey look all the tests pass
let's make a go/no-go decision here
buttons clicked we move to prod there
may be some approvals out to a change
management system you might still have a
cab
so there's something going on here with
some decision making typically that's
the basic idea of continuous delivery
you have something valuable in code you
want that in production but you don't
want to break things so what do we do
take our code make it software in a
build process now we want to make sure
we're not breaking so we're gonna test
our deployment process moving to QA
we're then gonna test the software with
automated testing ranee is the same
deployment process two-stage same
deployment process out to production
after doing more tests more checks
getting approvals that allows us to get
those changes into production quickly
and safely and that's continuous
delivery thank you if you have questions
please drop us a line and if you want to
see more videos like this in the future
be sure to LIKE and subscribe